good morning Hank it's Tuesday so when
Sara and I moved to New York in 2005 we
hired some people off Craigslist helped
us move our furniture into our new
apartment including a guy from I think
Eastern Europe and when I asked him why
he'd moved to the United States he said
in New York anyone who can work can work
which is like the best one Senate
summary of an efficient labor market
I've ever heard anyway when he asked me
what I did I told him that my first
novel Looking for Alaska had come out
recently and he said oh I want to work
in publishing and I was thinking you
know yeah book publishing is a good star
to hitch your wagon to and then we went
back to moving boxes flash-forward about
a year I met a big publishing conference
and a guy wearing a suit walks up to me
and says hey I moved you into your
apartment Looking for Alaska and it was
the guy from Craigslist and sure enough
he was working in international sales
for a huge publishing company and that's
the American dream right people come to
our fair shores because here anyone who
can work can work our national
self-understanding is supported by
anecdotes like this from the Craigslist
furniture mover to the impoverished
child turned steel magnate Andrew
Carnegie there Carnegie depending on how
pretentious you are but I think the
actual data is somewhat less dreamy
quick aside to all of you saying I
should say data are because data is a
plural noun come on right but anyway 42%
of American men raised in the bottom 20%
of incomes stay there in the UK that
number is 30% in Denmark it's 25% in
fact by almost any measure whether you
are born rich or poor in the United
States is a better indicator of whether
you will end up richer poor than it is
in Canada or Europe or any country in
the developed world when we talk about
socio-economic mobility and equality of
opportunity in the 21st century we're
not really talking about the American
dream we're talking about the Danish
dream
here's another metric that I think is
really interesting economic
opportunities for women in the United
States women make 77 cents for every
dollar that men make in the workforce
just to be clear that's horrific ly
unjust but it's also really economically
problematic because you don't want
people to be paid according to their sex
you want them to be paid according to
their skills and contributions so in the
u.s. women make 77 cents for every dude
dollar Canada is actually worse than us
but they have a little bit of a weird
economy but in Australia it's 83 cents
in the UK it's 84 in Sweden it's 85 and
in Slovenia the world's most underrated
country women make 90
7.5 cents for every dollar that men make
in the workforce I think the American
Dream remains uniquely American in one
sense we are far more likely than
residents of other countries to believe
that people are rewarded for
intelligence and skill and were less
likely to believe that coming from a
wealthy family is key to getting ahead
unfortunately like a lot of Dreams what
we're dreaming isn't real like I want to
add that the same regulations and
redistributed tax policies that allow
for better equality of opportunity and
the rest of the world do limit
innovation and that's definitely part of
the reason why hugely innovative
companies like Apple and Twitter and
Google and in-and-out burger all started
in the US but my worry is that systemic
inequality of opportunity will prevent
the most promising future innovators
from getting the opportunities they need
to succeed and I worried that the US
will become progressively less appealing
to the smartest people with the best
skills I mean the place where if you can
work you can work won't be the u.s.
anymore it'll be Denmark or Slovenia
like egg if you're a female computer
programmer today and you have both a
Slovenian and an American passport
you're probably still best off working
in the United States but if current
trends continue that may not be the case
in a decade and that's why systemic
inequality of opportunity is bad not
just for Americans living in poverty but
for all Americans by the way shout out
to slovenian readers of cry bozos Venza
I'm basically fluent in Slovenian I
think I also wanted to say thanks for
your video and consent and abuse it
really did make me proud to be your
brother tell my god what is this Esther
day I'll see you on Friday